[Music]
sometimes I think that night marked me
everything that came afterwards
[Music]
couldn't be a coincidence could it
brought in a kid last night it might be
something for that interests for me
Danny you don't really seem like a
dangerous person can you tell me how you
ended up here Luther hey I'm gonna kick
your little wiry ass
oh
you want to come here clean yourself up
you're safe now you never struck you as
strange that this man just showed up to
save you
figured I was lucky have you ever been
lucky
no
this blast everywhere signs of a
struggle a lot on the floor
what about the girl don't sign a hurry
either I'm thinking any officer
this wasn't a random shooting he's
hiding something
what happened in that house where did
they all go
we have these blank spots
they're not the only people close to you
to disappear are they
think these are all victims
can you see how all of this can seem
like it was you wait do you think that
I'm the one pulling the strings
what if I said I do I'm not
Danny I'm trying to help you I didn't
shoot anybody his best interest is to
plead guilty they're all in this
together is that right Danny may be
innocent what are you not telling me
what are you not telling yourself
[Music]